وصلت للتو الان السفينه الامريكيه برونز
ويك الى ميناء الجده الاسلامي وهي تقف على
رصيف رقم سبعه واربعين وهي من ضمن السفن
العسكريه الحربيه او كذلك التجاريه
الاجنبيه التي تقوم باجلاء رعايه من
جنسيات مختلفه ولعلها في مقدمه هذه
الجنسيات تحديدا على هذه السفينه هم رعايا
من امريكا وكذلك جنسيات اخرى طبعا هذه
السفينه هي هي ثاني سفن برونز ويك
الامريكيه العسكريه التي تقف على هذا
الرصيف تحديدا وهي تعتبر من العمليات
الاجلاء التي تقوم بها من بورتسودان الى
ابناء جده الاسلامي في غرب السعوديه طبعا
وصلت وفي هذه اللحظات وصلت والان نحن ما
زلنا في انتظار نزول الر الخاص او الجسر
الرابط من السفينه الى رصيف الميناء حتى
نتمكن من رصد ايضا
الرعايه الذين وصلوا عموما عدد الرعايه
على هذه السفينه تحديدا هم 200 من جنسيات
مختلفه ولعلها كانت في السفينه الاولى هم
عددهم
305 اشخاص كانت هناك ايضا اكثر من سته عشر
جنسيه ولكن حتى الان لم تصل دام ايضا من
من المسؤولين في السفاره الامريكيه عدد
الجنسيات تحديدا لهذه السفينه طبعا هذه
السفينه تحديدا نحن نتحدث عن سفينه انزال
اي انها تستخدم للعمليات العسكريه سواء في
عمليات الانزال العسكريه او كذلك في
عمليات الانسان الانزال للقوات الامريكيه
عند ذهابها وعندها
لعده مهام ولكن هذه المره الان نشاهد تقوم
بحمل رعايه من جنسيات مختلفه وعددهم 222
شخص طبعا هناك الجهات الامنيه والعسكريه
في السعوديه متواجده وكذلك الصحه للتابعه
للسعوديه او وزاره الصحه السعوديه ايضا
تتواجد لم تردنا ايضا حتى الان افاده
كامله ووافيه من قبل السفاره
الامريكيه اذا ما كانت هناك اصابات سواء
على متن هذه السفينه او ايضا حالات طارئه
صحيا ولكن كل ما ننتظره هو نزول هذا الرام
الذي نشاهده الان وهو الجسر الذي سوف يقوم
الرعايه بالنزول من بعد وصوله الى هذا
الرصيف على رصيف ميناء جده الاسلامي وبعد
ذلك يتم نزولهم بسلام وامان وتتم المرحله
التاليه بنقلهم عبر حافلات الى مقر
اقامتهم في الفنادق المحدده من اوله
وفرتها الخارجيه السعوديه طبعا ايضا على
ظهر السفينه نشاهد عدد من جنود البحريه
الامريكيه الذين يقفون بعضهم مسلح والبعض
الاخر ما زال يترقب عمليه نزول هؤلاء
الرعايه وكذلك في الجهه السفليه او في
الطابق ايضا السفلي من السفينه اعداد من
المهندسين او الفنيين الميكانيكيين الذين
هم مختصين في انزال هذا الرام وهو رام
بحري او الجسر الرابط بين
السفينه وكذلك الرصيف هنا في الجهه الاخرى
وصلت الحافلات الان للتو في انتظار ايضا
نزول الرعايه وكذلك توجههم الى هذه
الحافله بعد
اخذ الاذن الاخير والموافقه بنزولهم